Oyakodon for lunch is waiting for a win.
There is a line on the table, but it's a
short 30 minutes and it's a little less than 30 minutes.
It was made for the first time, but
now it is said that Tamahide and preservation are behind the scenes in Japan.
[Music]
Konosuke Yamada This is the
8th generation chicken dish called Tamahide.
The food called Oyakodon is on top of rice.  Birds and eggs are on board, but
since it's birds and eggs, it's a drug because I'm simply using both parents and children
.
What's wrong with chicken is a chicken-only refrigerator? Eggs are an egg-only dress. The
way to cut chicken is
probably the same as in the Edo era, but it's
basically the same.  The seasoning has become so much as the seasoning of Ichiko Soden.
However, Ichiko Soden does not mean making the same thing
again, but now it is incorporated into the gene dna and has the same spirit.  I think it's okay if the ears change a little if it's
included.
On the contrary, I'll
tell my son about
it. My son will tell my grandson again
.
I think it's better to continue for another 50 years, 100 years, and 200 years, rather than making more music profits in business.
[Music]
Boo